hey everybody what's going on uh
hopefully I have the okay just I forgot
to check if the microphone was still on
uh but yeah so hey everybody it's Monday
night and I'm here doing little movie
discussion like I would normally do on
Monday night um so probably because a
lot of you guys asked me about it on the
uh YouTube um you know Community tab
thingy or whatever like an update um on
Tom's dad and um I hate to say but it's
not really um great news seems like
yesterday he kind of rallied and he
seemed like he was a little bit better
but today um Tom went there and his
other family members are there and
basically this evening the doctors told
them well you know we've done all that
we can for him and we don't think that
he's going to recover so they are making
arrangements to take him to hospice
tomorrow so I asked Tom I'm like you
know are you okay and stuff like that
and Tom's like yeah I'm fine he's like I
was expecting this so it's like at least
I was here you know what I mean so it's
that like um so I said well do you want
me to update everybody on the show and
he said yeah he said he said to tell you
guys that
um Nature's taking over that's what he
said CU he's like his dad is just at
this point is just like sick of this
[__] you know what I mean um he's in a
lot of pain he has like multiple things
going on at one time and he's just like
I'm just kind of tired of being in the
hospital and he's just tired of dealing
with it so we'll see what happens but
they are going to take him to hospice
tomorrow so last cuz so Tom I think is
still at the hospital I just talked to
him about 20 minutes ago so that's uh
what's going on with that and like I
said I thought everybody would want an
update so as I said I'm not entirely
sure um when Tom's going to be back he
said that he's like well I wanted to
come back before the end of the week
because I don't want to have to pay to
rent the car for another day CU he paid
for the car rental for a week and he's
like and it was kind of expensive so
he's like I don't want to you know have
to go over but we'll see how it goes you
know what I mean like I said I can do
the show without him um you know if I
need to but he's kind of wanting to be
back like before the end of the week so
we'll see how that goes but yeah um like
I said I talked to him he's he seems
fine um you know what I mean like I said
he was expecting it and he was just glad
that he got to be there but like we'll
see what's going to happen you know what
I mean so I might talk to him on uh
maybe like over FaceTime or something
like that like later on because we
talked last night too but um but yeah
Danny says is that a wig or is that your
actual hair it's my actual hair today
actually um my hair was getting so so
[__] up and messy looking that I was
just kind of like Jesus Christ I got up
this morning and I was like I really
need to cut my bangs and I really need
to like do my roots again and [__] like
that so I cut the bangs and everything I
it's funny cuz I went out to I had to
run a bunch of errands today like I had
to return some [__] and all this other
stuff and um so I stopped and got lunch
at this like little Italian place and I
sent Tom a picture he's like oh send me
a picture of the place so I sent him a
picture of the restaurant and then I
took one of myself he's like oh you cut
your bangs it looks really you know what
I mean so I was like yeah finally cuz
they were getting to a point where they
were just like way down here in my eyes
and I had to like sweep them over to the
side and I [__] hate having to do
that but I'm just like too lazy it's
like I'm so lazy that I never cut them
it only takes a minute I don't know why
I do that but yeah so finally finally I
cut them today so yeah I do like them a
lot better when they're short but they
grow super fast uh Tammy says got my
mom's Arrangements all finished today
got to go to her apartment tomorrow and
start cleaning that yeah that's what I
mean it's just kind of like whatever
happens with Tom's dad it's like you
know they're going to have to go through
uh you know all all of his stuff and all
that kind of stuff so I don't know like
what he wanted for a funeral and so I
don't really know what's going on there
you know what I mean but I just wanted
to like kind of update
everybody um you know at one time so you
guys knew what was going on but you know
it's kind of a bummer but like he said I
was expecting it I'm just you know I'm
bummed out because of that and I'm also
bummed out cuz you know Tom's not here
and you know I miss him and stuff and so
I want him to come home but you know
what I mean it's like he's got to do
what he's got to do it's weird him not
being here well because like I said the
only time in how long have we been to
get for 13 years or however long we've
been together the only time we've ever
been apart I think we've only been
apart 2 weeks plus 5 days in that entire
13 years that's the only time you know
what I mean um so it's so it's weird
like him not being here you know what I
mean because we're almost always we're
not like jointed at the hip or anything
but we're almost always like in the
house house together you know so it's
it's just very strange him not being
here the cats are freaking out it's like
they don't know what's going on and
everything so you know I'm just kind of
hoping he comes back but you know uh are
you food cheating on Tom hey he's food
cheating on me too because it's like but
he sent me a thing and it's like
yesterday he's like hey I found this
Chinese buffet in uh you know the little
town that he's in he's like yeah it's
pretty good it's not as big but they
have some different stuff and then like
last night he was like oh I'm at this
place called wards which I guess is a
chain but it's only in Mississippi like
cuz I was like I never heard of that cuz
he sent me the sign and he's like oh
they have such a cool logo and all this
other stuff I was like I never really
heard of that and um he's like yeah they
have like chili burgers and hot dogs and
stuff like that like Southern stuff
biscuits and um yeah he said it was
pretty good but yeah he was sending me
pictures of the the stuff of the plays
and the sign and everything so he's
doing a lot of food cheating okay and I
was like I said I was out running
errands today and I was like man I
really I don't you know I don't like
cooking
so you know what I mean and I know
that's pitiful but it's I could cook if
I wanted to but it's like I just don't
want to so it's like whenever he's not
here I'm just like [__] man I'm just I'm
just G to go to Publix and get a sub or
something like that but I was up by the
UPS store because I had to return a
bunch of stuff and um you know there was
like this little Italian place over
there I was like H I wonder if that's
any good so I went in there it was
pretty good actually and it was um the
lunch special was actually quite
reasonable it was nine bucks and you got
like a I got a big thing of pasta and a
big thing of garlic knots and I was like
[__] man that's all I ate today
cuz it was that was plenty you know what
I
mean um yeah uh yeah Tammy said yeah the
hubs didn't come up here with me cuz my
mom's basically just having a small
viewing then it's getting cremated plus
we have two dogs and two cats he's taken
care of yeah that's what I mean it's
like when this whole [__] first happened
like Tom was like well why don't you
come with me and I was just like well
okay but then I was like oh wait it's
like who's going to take care of the
kitties and it's I I don't want to leave
them alone they will flip out um and I
was like and also like freelance work
like I have have freelance work coming
in whenever and I kind of have to do
that like when it comes in and it's I
didn't want to have to take like 40
bajillion laptops and all this other
kind of [__] so you know what I
mean um but you know so I was like well
that sucks but Tom's like it's okay it's
you know he's like I'll be back soon
don't worry about it so like I said
we'll see how it goes but I'm kind of
bummed out but you know let's cheer
ourselves up though by talking about a
movie from the
1940s about a serial
killer this is actually really really
good movie uh subjective perspective
Collective says I still haven't seen the
spiral staircase but I've heard it's a
Proto Galo um we'll watch it sooner than
later yeah it's kind I don't know if I'd
call it a Proto gialo it's kind of a
Proto slasher though uh for real which I
know that Gio and slasher are kind of
similar but Galo is very specific this
does have some very slasher elements to
it now the reason that I wanted to do
this one is because I'm still working on
this
gargantuan video that I'm doing that's
history of horror movies like I said I
think I talked about it I was talking
about a long time ago because I was like
oh I wanted to get up for
Halloween that didn't even come close to
happening I got maybe like half of the
script written and then I was like oh my
God there's no way um so then I'm like
oh maybe I'll get up for Christmas or
maybe it'll get for New Year's and still
um it is like I had the script all
written it's actually about half done
like as far as the editing goes um I'm
at the end of the
1970s so I just have like a few more
decades and then it'll be done like I
said I'm hoping to get it up I was
hoping to get it up by the end of last
week but obviously that didn't happen CU
a bunch of other stuff intervened like I
said Tom having do and all this other
kind of stuff and I didn't really feel
like working on it but um but I am going
to get it done but the thing about it
was that while I was working on that and
I was going back through um all the
classic old movies from you know the day
and everything and I was talking about
the 1940s and I was just kind of like oh
man the spiral staircase I remember
seeing that a really long time ago and
that was another one that I wanted to
rewatch cuz I remember really liking it
and I was like oh I should rewatch that
and like do a review on it because you
know like I said I remember really
liking it now as far as I don't know if
it's streaming anywhere else I watched
it on Plex for free so whether it's on
another streaming platform I don't know
but that's where I found it like you
might have I don't did it have
commercials it might have had
commercials now I can't remember it was
a couple days ago that I watched it but
I mean Plex usually has commercials but
they have a bunch of stuff on there
that's free there's you can usually find
it for free and I found it for
free so this movie cuz Okay so I feel
like and this was kind of um reinforced
to me when um I was when I you know
since I've been working on this history
of horror movies video it's always like
been hard for me because I love horror
movies from every decade right the 1940s
is the hardest for me to like find
there's good [__] but it's not as much
because cuz it does kind of seem like a
lot of the movies that came out in the '
40s there was kind of a lull you know
what I mean cuz like after the big like
Universal monsters and everything like
that in the 30s in the 1940s it seemed
like everything was just like sequels to
the universal monster movies and then
like in the mid-40s you know it was
World War II and people weren't really
going to the movies as much and it's
like they didn't really seem to want to
go to horror movies in particular so it
seemed like in the mid1 1940s it seemed
to go more in like a psychological
horror Thriller Direction um you know
like Alfred Hitchcock like he made
Spellbound I think that was 1945 and
then this movie came out in
1946 and this one it's like I said it's
usually called a psychological horror or
a thriller it has some kind of film Noir
uh kind of aspects to it as well um the
funny thing to me was that at the time
in 1946 when it came out it was actually
called a mystery romance which I guess I
mean there I don't know if I'd go so far
as to call it a romance there is kind of
like a little bit of a love story in it
but it's not like a sappy love story you
know I mean it's kind of on the just on
the
fringes but um and and like a subjective
perspective said this is this has been
called a Proto slasher and I can totally
see why because even though obviously
the term serial killer did not exist
until like the '70s I think before that
I'd seen it called mass murder I'd seen
phrases like that thrown around but I'd
never seen serial killer used until the
1970s but this is absolutely about a
serial
killer um you know I like I said there
have been ones before that I mean you
know Fritz Langs M that was from the 30s
that was about a serial killer um you
know what I mean so it wasn't like it
that they never did it but it was just
kind of like that was more like they
didn't really call those horror movies
and they didn't call this a horror movie
either and and I don't know if I call it
a horror horror movie it's psychological
horror it's a thriller kind of it's like
psycho kind of but it's Proto psycho so
um the yeah the thing about it is that
there's stuff in this that probably a
modern slasher fan would
recognize in the sense that I don't know
if I'd go so far as say it's like oh
like you know point of view shots from
the Killer and stuff but it is kind of
like that you know what I mean because
you do kind of see things from the
Killer's perspective um there are some
kind of jalow esque elements where they
show like close-ups of eyes like the
Killer's eye and stuff like that like in
a shadow which is kind of cool um so you
can see where the kind of slasher thing
came from and this totally has that so
this was actually directed by
um wait a minute yeah Alison says uh
she's mute not deaf yeah yeah yeah
that's that's right yeah she's mute
she's not deaf um but she can't talk
yeah we'll get into that so this was
directed
by uh Robert uh sadok uh the German
director
now he did a [__] ton of movies not just
horror movies um just a ton of different
kinds um but I think probably horror
fans will know him for directing son of
Dracula from
1943 um that was where I knew him from
cuz I knew that name so the movie is
actually adapted from a novel that came
out in
1933 and it was called some must watch
by Ethel Lena white now this is uh this
is crazy I didn't actually know this but
this was apparently a very popular novel
to adapt because even prior to the movie
coming out they had done like a radio
play of it um you know and after this
movie came out like three years later
they did another radio production of it
in
1949 and then it got three more film
adaptations there was one in 1961 that
had um Elizabeth Montgomery like famed
from Bewitched um and Lillian Gish in it
and then there was one in
1975 that had Jacqueline bassette in it
and one in 2000 that had nicholet
Sheridan in it I have seen none of those
um and a lot of them seem kind of hard
to get hold of so I don't know if they
were all that good I think the 2001
might have been made for TV or maybe the
1975 one was made for TV I can't really
remember but it's just weird that there
like five or six different adaptations
of this like one book that lady must
have been the lady that wrote it must
have just been raking in the royalties
I'm just saying it was adapted so many
times but like I said I think the more
recent you know the one from the 60s and
70s and uh 2000 um I hadn't heard of
those so I so I don't know if they're
any good or not I mean I would assume
that they if they were any good that
people would talk about them so I don't
know so what happened with the 1946
version
is that uh the famed producer David O
selnik he had actually bought the rights
to the novel now he was going to cast
ingred Bergman in the
lead but then later on you know various
things happened and he ended up selling
the rights to the book as well as a
bunch of other rights like to other
properties that he owned to RKO pictures
because he wanted to fund this Western
that he was making and he's like well I
don't need this stuff so he just sold
it's to
RKO so RKO starts production on the
movie in
1945 and they put Dorothy Maguire in the
lead role she's great in this by the way
now she actually won an Oscar like more
than a little more than a year after
this uh for the 1947 movie Gentleman's
Agreement um I recognized her from Old
Yeller uh from 1957 she was in that and
she was also Al in Swiss Family Robinson
from 1960 so you might recognize her
from that too cuz I knew she was
familiar and then I looked it up and I'm
like oh yeah that's where I know her
from um also this movie has a just a
fantastic performance by uh the
legendary Ethel
Barrymore who was an actor for more than
60 years I believe obviously the
Barrymore family very famous acting
family um she was known as the first
lady of American Theater so she's in
this too and I love her in this she's
fantastic she plays this crotchy old
lady she's she's
great so um oh Allison says Dorothy
Mcguire was great in Enchanted Cottage
oh I should see that actually because I
don't think I've uh I don't think I've
ever seen
that so the story of the spiral
staircase is actually I didn't realize
this this when I was watching it but
then when I was thinking about it I was
like oh yeah I guess so it's set over a
a day and a night so it's just a single
day pretty much that the that all the
[__] happened so it was quite a day is
what I'm saying now it's actually set in
the early 20th century um I don't know
if they say specifically in the movie
but when I looked it up they said it's
supposed to be 1906 so there's that and
it's in this little village in Vermont
somewhere like you know so Dorothy
Maguire plays the main character whose
name is Helen now she's a mute woman and
she works as this kind of caregiver
companion type person to this kind of
sick old woman who lives this massive
you know kind of Family Estate
right so the beginning of the movie It's
Helen's day off and she's at this Inn I
guess like a hotel type thing like in
the village and they're doing like a
movie showing because I guess this is
1906 so they didn't have movie theaters
per se they just kind of had this room
with like a curtain across it and you
went in there to like and they had a
projector you know what I mean so that's
what she with a bunch of chairs so
that's what she's doing doing she's
sitting there with a bunch of other
people like watching a silent
movie now while her and the other people
are watching movie you know this is an
inn or hotel or whatever so people live
there so there's a bunch of rooms
upstairs so while they're all watching
the movie this woman in one of the rooms
upstairs gets
murdered now this
woman has what all of the characters
refer to as an Affliction which in
modern parlons you would call a
disability right um in her case I
believe she's a
paraplegic so they have like the
Constable comes there and like
everybody's freaking out and then he's
questioning
everybody and he gets some he gives some
Exposition about um this is actually the
third recent murder uh that has happened
and all of the victims were disabled
somehow like this one is a paraplegic
there was one that had like a really bad
um like a disfiguring scar on her face
and then there was one that was quote
unquote simple-minded that's what he
said so I was like okay so so again this
is three victims now so we have an
official serial
killer now because this is kind of a
small town evidently and everybody knows
Helen and knows about her
mutinus they start getting concerned
that she's going to be the next Target
right so she's at this this Inn and
they're like well it's a 2 mile walk
back to your well it's not her house but
it's where she works and I presume she
lives there as well she's like a livein
caregiver um so they're like okay well
it's 2 miles away so you better like
hurry up and get there before it gets
dark you know you don't want to get
murdered too because you never know what
might happen right so she's walking home
and luckily for her she gets met on the
road by a friend of hers who also turns
out as a potential Suitor that's where
the romance part comes in uh and his
name is Dr Perry and he's played by Kent
Smith who I immediately recognize from
cat people from 1942 the jacqu Tor movie
who um that valuten produced and he
actually gives her a lift back to the
house like in his horse and trap
handsome what do they call that I don't
know like you know what I mean it's like
the little thingy um did it have a horse
oh [__] now I can't remember it wasn't a
car car cuz it was
1906 so there's kind of like a bit of a
subplot it kind of plays into the story
like a little not hugely but there is
like a little bit of a sideline where Dr
Perry is apparently kind of new in town
and so he has something of a rivalry
going on with um The Village's kind of
crotchety old doctor whose name is Dr
Harvey so there's kind of a thing about
that where he where the old guy is like
you know you're stealing my patience
young upstart blah blah blah and there's
this whole thing about patience oh he
called me instead of the old guy and
stuff so you know there's kind of that
plays into the whole thing too a little
bit so um subjective perspective said
are you doing spoilers um I probably
will because the movie is so old so yeah
I probably should have said
that Allison said I saw the one with
Nicollet Sheridan not awful oh okay I
didn't even know it existed until after
I saw this one you know what I mean
that's crazy I don't think I ever saw a
single thing that Nicollet Sheran was in
not that I remember now I'm going to
have to watch him I it's all kind of
interesting Danny says ingr Bergman was
a fox especially in the Hitchcock film
Spellbound yeah I want to do Spellbound
as well cuz I haven't seen that in a
really long time yeah the film that
inspired the Phantom killer of Tex
Arcana during the dream sequence yeah
that's right but um but yeah that's
another great movie that just came out
like a year before this one but yeah so
yeah so I probably will do spoilers
because like I said it's an older movie
and I know maybe a lot of people haven't
seen it but you know it's hard to talk
about movies without doing spoilers you
know so I I usually have a thing where
if the movie is old enough
um then usually I will do spoilers but
if it's new then I won't you know so
that's what I'm just saying so I
probably will tell you who the Killer is
that's that's all I'm going to
say so Dr Perry is given uh Helen a ride
and drops her off at the front Gates of
the estate or whatever and then there's
this really really good sequence there
like this really bad storm kind of blows
up out of nowhere right so it's like all
this wind and rain and stuff and then
Helen starts getting really nervous
because as she's going up to because
it's just like the front gate and
there's this big long [__] driveway
or whatever and so she starts hearing
rustling in the bushes like
nearby so um the wrestling actually
turns out just to be like a little bunny
rabbit or something but uh we as the
audience see that there's this kind of
shadowy figure of a dude standing over
like among the trees like watching her
you know what I mean so we know there's
somebody watching her but she doesn't
know um and then he kind of like like
she drops her key like in the mud and is
kind of fumbling around for it and so he
kind of starts to come at her but she
doesn't see him you know what I mean um
but then she kind of finds it and she's
like oh [__] cuz she's getting freaked
out cuz she hears stuff and she wants to
get back to the house she's getting all
wet so she kind of hauls ass to the
house and then you see the stalker
person whoever it is um kind of backing
off she's like oh you're and you're
assuming he's like oh he's waiting for
his moment or
whatever so she gets inside the house
and at that point we kind of are slowly
introduced to the rest of the people in
the
household so the matriarch of the family
is this bedridden woman named Mrs Warren
and that's Ethel Barrymore um she's real
cantankerous but also kind of awesome
like I loved her she's super cranky and
she's she's like my spirit animal and
she's kind of like she kind of seems to
know everything about everything about
like what's going on in the house house
even though she seemingly never leaves
her room like I don't think she can get
up or walk around or anything so there's
that so she's there uh there's also her
stepson whose name is Professor Albert
Warren and then she has um yeah that
she's the Stepmom so that's her stepson
and then it's her real son whose name is
Steph now stevenh is kind of this
smirking Playboy arrogant type dude and
he's just come back from
Europe uh for a visit or whatever now
stepen has also been apparently uh
having an affair well is it an affair
neither of them are married so I guess
he's having a relationship with um
Albert's secretary whose name is blanch
uh she also seems to live in the house I
presume so um rounding out the kind of
residence potential suspects in the
house cuz this is like a murder mystery
you know what I mean uh you got a
housekeeper ER named Mrs oats who's
actually played by Guess Who Elsa
Lanchester that's right the Bride of
Frankenstein herself uh plays a
housekeeper in this one she's also a lot
of fun um she has her husband is uh Mr
oats who's like the grounds keeper or
whatever he's not in at a huge amount
and um you have this nurse nurse Barker
and this part is kind of funny because
there's like a running gag in the movie
I don't know if I call it a gag but it's
kind of like a running thing like
through the movie where Where Mrs Warren
like hates the nurse like she like the
nurse will come in to like do stuff like
give her medicine and she's like Helen
can do that get out of my face you know
what I mean so it's just so like Mrs
waren just like hates her so much and
she just like she never wants her to do
anything except like sit out in the
hallway and leave her alone so the nurse
is always complaining he's like what the
hell are you been paying me for she's
like I'm paying you to sit out in the
hall now [__] off you know what I mean
and it's like so funny but it's I don't
know I just found that really funny it's
not like zany like the way they do it
there's there's some humor in the movie
but it's not like wacky over the-top
humor you know what I mean cuz I know
some movies back then kind of had some
kind of over- the toop humor but this it
has funny stuff in it but it's not like
super wacky funny but I just thought
that was very funny that she's like I
pay you to sit out in the hall you know
what I mean it's like the nurse doesn't
do anything uh also you have the
adorable and very good boy Carlton the
Bulldog um now he gets threatened with
beatings several times by Mrs oats AKA
Elsa Lanchester because he's constantly
like underfoot I guess and she's always
like tripping over him but um you know
he he doesn't get harmed in any way so
don't worry about that even though she
does kind of be like I'm GNA hit you you
know what I mean and I was like don't
you you leave that dog alone leave the
dogs alone but he doesn't get hurt he's
fine and he doesn't even care he's just
like yeah whatever bring it so you know
what I mean um I'll will also note
spoiler alert Carlton is not the
murderer so there's that that would be
funny if he if the dog wants to murder
yeah Alison I love loved Carlton Carlton
was great he was like the best character
he was just like his little face was
just so's he's like a pug or something
right or a bulog he's a bulldog rather I
said Bulldog before why did I say pug I
don't know because I was watching a
video of a pug earlier that's why but
yeah so he's a bulldog and he's just has
like he's just like H whatever just
laying around the floor so everybody can
trip over
him um now shortly after Helen gets back
in the house Mrs oats finds this window
open that she's sure that she closed
before and you know like I said this big
storm blew up so it's kind of like
blowing all this wind and rain and [__]
like that into the window and she's like
who the hell opened this and then she
like almost kind of like lowkey blames
the dog which I was like that really
would be something if the dog had opened
the window I think she even says you're
not even you're not that clever she says
to him and I was like and the dog's
probably like I totally did open that
that would be like super funny um but
yeah so this window is open so you're
just like uhoh you know what I mean cuz
you've already seen like a dude like
lurking around outside and then um you
actually see like the feet like the
bottom part of the legs and feet of a
dude who's kind of clearly skullking
around like in the shadows of the house
like watching Helen as she's doing her
[__] you know what I mean so you're led
to assume that this person has like
climbed in the window and is now like
skullking around the house like I said
so and it's going to kill people and
you're assuming that this is the same
person that you know killed the lady at
the Inn earlier and has perhaps followed
Helen home that's what they want you to
think
anyway so Helen um because she's running
late and it's funny because everyone
[__] at her even though she's like
dude well she doesn't say this but this
is what I would say she's like dude I
was out of the movies somebody got
murdered like so I had to be there for
the police investigation or whatever and
then on the way home like there was a
horrible storm so cut me some slack you
know what I mean but no nobody does so
they all kind of yell at her for being
late
so she goes up to talk to Mrs
Warren um and the cranky old bat kind of
spookily tells her you know you're in
danger you should pack your bags and
like get the [__] out of this house
tonight um you know if you won't go you
know I want you to go if you won't go at
least stay in this room tonight because
I think you're really in danger now she
won't specify like who the danger is
from or what the danger is
specifically but you know considering
that we've seen that there is a dude
creeping around the house perhaps um you
know maybe she's psychic and she's may
be on to something you know like I said
they do kind of um they kind of build up
the fact that they don't say she's
psychic or nothing like that but the um
like the nurse and stuff is just like I
swear she knows everything that goes on
in here even though she just stays in
that room you know what I mean so and
just like she always seems like she's
watching you so there's that kind of
stuff so happily for Helen um you know
as far as having to leave the house and
stuff Dr Perry who picked her up before
um he has pretty much um professed his
love for her and his intention to marry
her and he wants to take her away from
the house now specifically he wants to
take her to a specialist in Boston who
can maybe help her get her voice back
now it's at this point because before
they didn't really say like everyone
know she's mute but nobody really says
why you're you're led to assume that
it's some kind of psychological issue
and indeed that is what it turns out to
be so we discover that Helen has been
mute since she was a child when she
witnessed her house burning down with
her parents still in it um you know so
she basically watched her parents burn
to death which you know you can't blame
her for not talking after that it's a
little
traumatic so the scene where we find
this out is is kind of weird because Dr
Perry apparently went somewhere else and
found because she because obviously
Helen didn't tell anybody like why she
was
mute and um but Dr Perry found out from
somebody I guess from her doctor or
something from some other doctor so he
found out about it and he comes back and
like tells her that he knows and then he
like kind of yells what happened like
you know your parents burned to death
and the thing like he kind of grabs her
by the arms and he's like yelling it to
into her face and I was like bro it you
know what I mean it seemed a little
strange so um I get that he was
maybe um you know and he seemed pretty
chill up to this
point but so he just kind of went it
almost like I don't want to say violent
but he kind of came across as like you
know kind of just going to shake her you
know what I mean because he wanted her
to talk and so I mean I get that he was
trying to like force her to confront the
trauma um and get past it so she would
be able to talk again but it does kind
of come out of left field a little bit
and I kind of Wonder If part of the
scene's purpose was maybe to cast
suspicion on Dr Perry is the murderer
because like I said this is a murder
mystery so everybody is going to have
like motive or they're going to try and
cast suspicion on like pretty much
everybody so you don't guess who it is
you know what I mean so I wondered if
this was like a scene where they were
just like hey you know he can flip out
and be kind of like that tooo so maybe
it's him you know so there was that cuz
he seemed like pretty nice up to up to
this
point now meanwhile blanch who is uh the
professor's uh
secretary and you know she was the one
that's been [__] Steph the stepson or
no he's the real son yeah that's right
so um so they have a falling out which
is not surprising because Stephen is a a
douche Berger you know what I mean um
you know he's he's just a real dick so
so they have a fight and blanch decides
you know what I'm gonna leave this damn
house too I'm gonna get ad all like when
Helen goes like you know and Dr Perry's
like okay cool I'll give you a ride so
blanch goes okay I'm gonna go pack my
[__] I'm gonna get out of here too now
it so happens at this point that Dr
Perry gets called away to like see
another patient in town so and it's
nighttime at this point so he tells okay
well Helen and blanch you guys sit tight
until I get back like I'll be back later
this evening and then we'll get the [__]
out of here but later on he kind of
sends word back to them oh I won't be
able to get back to the estate tonight
cuz the patient that I went to see is
like way worse than I thought and I have
to stay here with him you know what I
mean so and it so happens too that the
only other um one of the other men in
the house who's Mr oats the grounds
keeper he has to get sent into town for
um some ether because Mrs Warren who
needed The Ether I guess they just put
kept putting that in her face all the
time to like wake her back up whenever
she went out into one of her fugues or
whatever so somebody stole the ether
that was there um they they don't know
who so it was gone and so they sent Mr
oats they said well you have to go get
some ether and it there were wasn't any
in town cuz Dr Perry had already said oh
I looked for some earlier today and they
didn't have any so he's like well [__]
have to go to the next town over which
is like a couple hours away so so a lot
of the men are kind of being sent away
you know what I mean so there's that
kind of
thing now it so happens that after Dr
Perry
leaves uh blanch goes down to the
basement to get her suitcase to put all
her [__] in and she gets murdered by
this person that's been skullking around
the house apparently so there's that now
I'm going to say like I said and this is
spoil spoiler alert spoiler alert
spoiler alert um you know this is a very
old movie uh nostalgic Top Hat says be
sure to read the Source book for 1930s
it holds up well I actually would like
to read the book I haven't read the book
um but yeah I I usually like to read the
books that these uh movies are based
on so up to this point um the movie has
been leaning pretty hard into the theory
that stepen is the Killer and there 's a
bunch of stuff like pointing to this
like for example earlier in the story
like near the beginning when the murder
thing was H when the murder was
happening at the in/ movie theater
situation the Constable says oh we've
tracked the killer to this area like
where this family's house is the estate
is um the murders only started after
Steven got back to town from
Europe um as I mentioned he's portrayed
as just the this real arrogant douche
who sort of like lowkey sexually
harasses blanch like every time he gets
the chance he's super pushy and he also
lies to the cops about being outside the
house like when they tell him it's like
did you even he's like I didn't even
leave the house today even though like
later on his uh step brother is all like
You' got mud all over your shoes though
you know what I mean so why' you lie to
the police so there's that now he says
he lied to the police because it's like
oh I was outside cavorting with blanch
and I didn't want anybody know about it
um but you know he still lied to the
cops about it so they thought that was
kind of sus now because of all of this
stuff um you're also led to assume that
Mrs Warren who is Stephen's mom also
thinks he's the murderer because at one
point she very cryptically says that um
and she says this to Howen it's like oh
there's always trouble when he comes
home that's what she says there's always
trouble now because of all of this setup
I'm pretty sure that Mo modern audiences
because we know all the tropes by now um
will pretty likely guess that it isn't
him uh because it's really never the
most obvious suspect and and you know
this was pretty early days um but I
think even by this point like that trip
was pretty well established it's never
because in mystery novels and stuff like
that it's never the most obvious person
and if the mystery writer is good enough
then they can you know make the murderer
like at the end like you didn't guess it
was them but then like once it's
revealed you're like oh that makes total
sense but sometimes and I don't think it
was the case with this maybe a little
bit but um it's a case where they push
really hard like for you to think hey
this is like red herring red hering like
it's this person and then so you know
that it's not that person because
they're not going to make it that easy
for you like they're not going to make
it that obvious and you know that
they're trying to like distract from
somebody else so I feel like like I said
I don't I feel like this was like right
on the edge because they were it was
very clear that they were trying to make
you think that it was Steven so like I
said modern audience that I was just
kind of like Well it can't be him
because they really wanted me to think
it's him so I know it's
not um so Helen though probably not
surprisingly because even his step's mom
thinks it's him Helen also thinks it's
him so she's the one she goes she's down
in the basement I can't remember why she
went down there but she goes down there
and she's the one that finds blanches
body and then Steph shows up
conveniently like seconds later and you
know again understandably she freaks the
[__] out like as you would and just
bolts and then she does the smart thing
and locks his ass in the Celler because
she thinks he's the killer
right then she attempts to call the
police I guess momentarily in her Panic
like forgetting that she can't talk so
so she picks up the phone and it's 1906
so phones were not were kind of a new
technology you know what I mean so she
picks it up and then she's just kind of
you can see the look in her face like oh
[__] you know what I mean like I kind of
forgot and like the lady at the other
end is like you know what what's going
on like number pleas or whatever the the
operator is saying and she's just
sitting there like flipping out because
she can't say
anything um so then she sees Albert the
step brother and she's just like
flipping out and she's like running to
him and she's like and then so she
writes down she's like Steven killed
blanch and it's like and I locked him in
the cellar you know
now at this point I admit for a second I
was just kind of like wouldn't it be
something because I was just being
fanciful earlier when I said wouldn't it
be funny if they made the Bulldog the
killer because that that really would be
something wouldn't it but I said um
wouldn't it be funny if they made it
that Dr Perry was the killer just
because it would have been such a
surprise because he was the least
obvious [__] right um in
hindsight I'm glad that they did not do
that because there wasn't really any
buildup for that there wasn't anything
pointing to him being guilty other than
that one scene where he very strangely
got very intense like an in her face
about Andre perz burned to death you
know what I mean and I was just like bro
you know what I mean chill out um like I
said I get what he was trying to do he's
a doctor and he was trying to help her
and everything like that but I was like
that's still kind of [__] up um so I
was like but there wasn't anything else
like pointing to him being that and so I
feel like if they had made him the
killer it would have been just kind of
like a cheap maneuver just for shock
value or whatever so it turns out again
spoiler alert spoil alert yeah Allison
said the cat did it I mean maybe I mean
the cat the cat pushed something off the
off the mantle and it fell on their head
and killed them I'm sure that there has
been at least one time in history that
that must have happened so the cat
really did do it and the cat doesn't
give a [__] either it's just like eh
whatever just pushing stuff just pushing
stuff off the mle like you do so so
there was that so spoiler alert it turn
it turns out that the Killer is actually
the first person that I thought it was
like as soon as this character was
introduced I was just kind of like like
oh that's the [__] right there
and I was right um you know what I mean
it was the first person that that I
thought of um it turned out to be
Professor Albert that's who the Killer
is and his motivation they don't go
super into because like I said this was
the 40s and the book came out in the
1930s so you didn't really get you know
he was a serial killer but you didn't
really get these kind of deep dives into
like serial killer psychology like you
would maybe get nowadays um you know
even psycho didn't really have that too
much they just kind of had a little bit
of exposition at the end like as to why
Norma Bates did what he did and it was
still it was the same kind of thing here
where they had established earlier on
that um both Albert and Stephen um they
had the same dad you know what I mean
because the Mrs waren was the Stepmom so
they had the same father but their
father was like this big like great
white Hunter type and he thought
basically that both of the sons were
pansies essentially they didn't use that
word but that's what he meant um you
know none of them liked hunting and none
of them liked guns and they weren't
manly man and and everything like that
so they were like big huge
disappointments so he would always um
kind of berate them for being you know
weak ass [__] or whatnot so because
um all of that had so warped Albert's
sensibility that he decided that he was
going to
Target people who were weak and
imperfect in some way hence why he went
after women that had disabilities
because they had something wrong with
them so obviously they needed to be
eliminated you know what I mean so
that's kind of like I said it's not it
wasn't a huge like psychological thing
but they kind of just went into a little
bit like that's why he killed
people he was also so sneaky because I'm
sitting there thinking well it's like
what he only just started killing people
just now like even though he's like in
his 40s or however old he was but what
he was doing was that he would only do
[__] like he would only commit crimes
when Steven was home so that he could
kind of like blame it on him you know
what I mean like he was trying to like
elay suspicion because Stephen was such
a douche that everybody believed even
his mom believed he was the killer which
that's got to hurt you know what I mean
so there was that um but yeah so he had
enough self-control to like wait until
Stephen was home and he's like oh now
I'm going to go out and kill a bunch of
people and then they'll just think it's
him even though they can't really prove
it you know what I mean so it's that
kind of thing
so at this point uh Albert reveals this
he's like oh I'm so glad that you locked
Steven in the basement like all of the
men are gone now like Mr oats went to
town and Dr Perry had to go on a on a
thing and um you know and then you
locked Stephen in the basement so waha
you know now I'm now I'm going to kill
you because she is also imperfect
because she can't talk so at the last
minute I love this ending I had to say I
I love this at the last minute like
she's just like oh [__] like and he's
going to to kill her and then the badass
elderly Avenger Mrs Warren staggers out
her bed for the first time I didn't even
know she could walk actually she just
kind of staggers out to bed and blows
her [__] stepson away with her
husband's hunting rifle just blam blam
blam blam she like [__] shoots the
[__] up they don't show it like they
show the gun going off and he just kind
of slides down the wall but they don't
show bullet holes like they would
nowadays cuz you know it's the 40s they
can't show people getting like blasted
like that
um and I love too how he's sliding down
the wall like oh [__] like he's dying
and stuff and she's like murderer you
know what I mean like she just like
wanted him to hear her say it like while
he was dying I'm like that is [__]
rad I love that so yeah he's he's like
sliding down the wall and dying and
she's like saying murder into his face
and I was like that is
badass um so Helen I mean because you
know any movie I think every movie that
I've ever seen that had a mute character
um something traumatic is is going to
happen and they're going to scream and
then they're going to be able to talk
again and um you know what I mean um and
like I said this was the 40s so this was
probably not a huge Trope then nowadays
you know that if there's a mute
character something bad's going to
happen they're going to scream and then
they're like oh yay I can talk you know
what I mean and that's what happens here
she sees him get shot and she's like you
know what I mean and she freaks out and
then she decides she can talk again so
um Steven gets released from the
basement he's probably a little put out
I
imagine and Mrs Warren um who you know
staggering out of her bed and shooting
her stepson has plum tuckered her out I
mean she's dying anyway um now she
actually to her credit does profusely
apologize to Stephen for thinking that
he was the killer this whole time and I
was like well that's nice that she did
that anyway and it's like she so she's
basically laying in uh her son's arms
and she's like I'm so sorry you know I
thought it was you all this time and
stuff like that and then she dies but at
least she said that like before she died
so that was kind of nice um and and then
Helen uh goes to the phone and calls Dr
Perry um you know and she's finally able
to speak to him for the first time
probably being like get me the [__] out
of here oh my God you know what I mean
um but yeah so there's that so like I
said this is on Plex at the moment um so
you can watch it for free and it's
really good I liked it a lot it's like
you know one of the best horror horror
adjacent movies from the
1940s um you know the cinematography is
really nice um the acting is really good
I especially liked Ethel Barrymore's
character she was fantastic but um you
know uh the woman that played hen
Dorothy Maguire was good too um
everybody in this is really really good
um and it's really suspenseful um
actually some contemporary critics
compared it like to an Alfred Hitchcock
movie so you know what I mean um you
know it and it is kind of it is very
hitchcockian now as I said it'll be
probably pretty obvious to Modern
viewers who the Killer is is like from
pretty early on um because and that's
not and that's not a ding on the writing
or anything like that that's just
because we've seen so many movies like
that like that since um you know that
time period so it's like everybody's
familiar with the tropes now in a way
that they maybe weren't as much in the
1940s so you know so so I don't really
think that that's too much of a a
detriment um because it's still a great
watch in spite of that and I really like
the way they balanced um just kind of
like this creepy suspense
atmosphere with kind of occasional hints
of levity like I said there is funny
stuff in it like the whole uh running
gag about the nurse that Mrs Warren
hates but still keeps her on the payroll
for some reason like that you never find
out what that reason is um you know and
the stuff with Mrs oats like Elsa
lanchester's character like keeps
tripping over the dog and oh and there's
also I forgot to mention this but um Mrs
oats there's also like funny scenes
where she's um kind of a drunk and so
she's always like like trying to consp
ire to kind of get so there's like a
really funny scene where she's trying to
like go into the cellar and like get
some Brandy without the guy that like
without the professor like finding out
about it so she's kind of like brings a
candle in there and she's like oh whoops
I dropped it and then she's like and
then I put the stuff in the pocket it's
like I thought that was like really
funny but like I said it's like it's not
super zany but it's just kind of like I
don't know it was just kind of like droy
funny I found it really really amusing
because I I love Elsa Lanchester and
she's like super charming and that she's
not in it a huge amount cuz she just
plays the housekeeper but she's in it
quite a bit so I love the scene where
she was like stealing the she was like
stealing the Brandy from the seller so
that was like pretty awesome um so I
mean if you're at all into classic
horror horror from this era um yeah you
should definitely see this one and like
I said if you're real into slashers you
might want to give it a look too because
um it's kind of like a very early it's
not a slasher movie but there are
slasher elements like you'll see stuff
that kind of came about like later on so
it might be interesting to see like if
you're into later slashers like from a
historical perspective like it might be
interesting to see where some of that
came from um so yeah it's like I said
it's great everybody should see it um I
don't talk about it that much on my
history of horror video that I'm going
to put up eventually whenever I get it
finish editing it um because I just
mentioned it on there but I think me
mentioning it made me want to watch it
again so that's kind of why I ended up
talking about it today um Danny says
that sounds like the ending of blood
Rage that's another one that I we
haven't done that one have we that was
another one that I need to
do um Tammy said off topic but I saw
where they're thinking about making
another season of Mind Hunters I heard
about that too I heard about that too I
kind of want to see
that um let's see new Planet of the Apes
yeah okay so I guess I will wrap this up
like I said cuz
this has cheered me up though talking
about a movie about serial killers this
is a good movie I like talking about
movies you know what I mean so kind of
take my mind off things for a little
while tamy said send Tom our best oh I
definitely will um like I said I might
FaceTime with him later tonight um and
we'll see what's going on and for
Wednesday night's show I'll still do
Wednesday night show but like I said
there was a poll and you know Jeffrey
Epstein was in the poll and obviously
that won by a significant margin and I
was like wait I can't do the Jeffrey
Epstein show without Tom here because we
really he really needs to be here for
that so I said well what I'll do is I'll
just do on Wednesday night's show
because I'm I'm 95% sure that Tom won't
be back by the time of Wednesday
night um then I'll just do what the
second place winner which was NASA Zone
F which was something I didn't really
know there's not a huge amount of
information about it but it'll I think
it'll be a good show anyway I didn't
know anything about it and I just kind
of like looked it up and it has to do
with um
megalodons too so we got to talk about
megalodons so I'll just do that one
because I said well I can do that one on
my own without because like I said the
Jeffrey Epstein thing Tom has to be here
for this so I'm going to push that back
till the following week so we can do
that one together so that's what we're
going to
do um but yeah Tammy said this chat has
made my crappy day better a that's good
that's good see it always like I said it
always kind of Cheers me up like doing
this because before I was just kind like
man it's just cuz I only just heard like
the news from Tom like 20 minutes before
this and I was just kind of like oh man
that's a bummer and it's like do I even
want to I thought it would be weird but
I was just kind of like no I it'll be
okay like it'll it'll cheer me up so so
there's that but yeah so um hopefully
you guys have a good rest of your
evening and thanks everybody for
stopping by and talking to me tonight uh
and cheering me up and uh yeah I'll see
you guys again on Wednesday night so
have a good
night